if the financial system is uh
evolutionary nature much like life on
earth what is the origin of money on
earth
the origin of money
predates coins most people kind of
assume i'll talk about coins but coins
are relatively late
developments
back in ancient mesopotamia so i don't
know 5 000 years ago
there were
relations between creditors and debtors
there there are even in the simplest
economy
uh because of the way in which
agriculture works
hey i need i need to
plant these seeds but i'm not going to
have crops for x months
so we have clay tablets in which
simple debt transactions are inscribed i
remember looking at great numbers of
these in the british museum when i was
writing the ascent of money and that's
really
the beginning of money the minute you
start recording a relationship between a
creditor and a debtor you have something
that is quasi money
and that is probably what these um
clay tablets mostly
denoted
from that point on
there's a great evolutionary experiment
to see what the most convenient way is
to
record
relations between creditors and debtors
and
what emerges
in the time of the ancient greeks
are coins metal
tokens
sometimes
a valuable metal sometimes not usually
bearing the imprint of a state or a
monarch
and that's the sort of more familiar
form of of money that we still use today
for very very small transactions i
expect coins will
all be gone by the time
my youngest son is my age but but
they're a last remnant of a very very
old way of of doing
of doing simple transactions and when
you say coins you mean physical coins
i'm talking about coins have been
rebranded into digital space not coin
based coins actual coin coins you know
the ones that jangle in your in your
pocket and you kind of don't know quite
what to do with once you have some
so
that that became an incredibly
pervasive
form of of of paying for things money is
just a
it's just a crystallization of a
relationship between a debtor and a
creditor and coins are just very
fungible
you know whereas a clay tablet relates
to a specific transaction
coins are generic and fungible they can
be used in in any transaction so that
was an important evolutionary advance
if you think of financial history and
this was the point of the ascent of
money as an evolutionary story there are
punctuated equilibria
people get by with coins for a long time
despite their defects as a means of
payment
such as that they can be debased
they can be clipped uh it's very hard to
avoid
fake or debased money entering the
system
but coinage is still kind of the basis
of payments all the way
through the roman empire out the other
end into the so-called dark ages it's
still how most things are settled
in cash transactions in the early 1300s
you don't get a big shift until after
the black death
when there is such a need to monetize
the economy because of chronic labor
shortages and feudalism begins to
unravel
that you you just don't have a
sufficient uh amount of coinage and so
you get bills of exchange and i'm really
into bills of exchange
because and this i hope will capture
your listeners
uh and viewers imaginations
when they start using bills of exchange
which which are really just pieces of
paper saying you know i owe you over a
three-month period while goods are in
transit from
florence to london
you get the first
uh peer-to-peer payment system which is
network verified because they're they're
not coins they don't have a king's head
on them they're just pieces of paper
and the verification comes in the form
of signatures and you you need
ultimately some kind of
guarantee if
i write an iou to you build exchange i
mean you don't really know me that well
we only just met so you might want to
get endorsed by i don't know somebody
really credit worthy like elon
and so we we actually can see in the
late 14th century in northern italy in
england and elsewhere the evolution of a
peer-to-peer network system of of
payment and that's actually how world
trade grows because you just couldn't
settle
long oceanic transactions with coinage
it just wasn't practical
all those
treasure chests full of the balloons
which were part of the way in which the
spanish empire worked really inefficient
so bills of exchange are an exciting uh
part of the story and they illustrate
something i should have made more clear
of the ascent of money
that not everything used in payment
needs to be money
classically economists will tell you ah
well money money has three different
functions
it's you've heard this a zillion times
right it's a unit of account it's a
store of value and it's a medium of
exchange
now there are three
or four things that are worth saying
about this and i'll just say two one
it may be that those three things are a
trilemma and it's very difficult for
anything to be all of them this point
was made by my hoover colleague manny
rincon cruz last year and i still wish
he would write this up as a paper
because it's a great insight
the second thing that's really
interesting to me is that payments don't
need to be money
and if we go around as economists love
to do saying well bitcoin's not money
because it doesn't fulfill these
criteria
we're missing the point that you could
build a system of payments
which i think is how we should think
about crypto that is isn't money doesn't
need to be money it's like bills of
exchange it's network-based
verification
peer-to-peer transactions without
without third-party verification
when it hit me the other day that we
actually had this precedent for crypto i
got quite excited and thought
i wish i had written that in the ascent
of money
you